let's talk about from a chemical
perspective so when we're interacting
with people there are three basic
chemicals that we're interested in and i
would promise i'll keep the science
lesson brief just just for us to
understand
the first one that we're looking for is
oxytocin so oxytocin does a lot of
things in our body but very basically it
makes us feel connected so when we're
making eye contact with people when we
hand shake we touch we have me too
moments we have moments where like oh
you do that yes i do that too
that all produces this chemical that
makes us feel warm and fuzzies and
literally they've proven this they've
they've synthesized oxytocin they've
found that if people do nose sprays
oxygen like
those sprays
they will participate collaborate and
give away more money in prisoner's
dilemma games oh my god there's there's
a whole market for this now yeah
i suppose no spray on the way into a
charity event i'm i'm a little terrified
like that's gonna happen like i always
wonder sometimes if i smell something
weird in a hotel if they're like pumping
oxytocin into the room so oxytocin so
oxytocin is like that's why
in some of those moments i'm we're
talking about like welcoming people
having me too saying yes yes i have that
too the other thing that we're looking
for is dopamine so dopamine is very
simplified the chemical of pleasure
more than just pleasure it's also the
chemical of motivation
when we feel excited about something we
want to learn more this is why when i
answer a question that i haven't
answered before it actually gives myself
dopamine right like i get to share a
story i haven't shared so my secret push
for asking non socially scripted
questions the secret reason i'm doing
that is not only because you might find
out something it's also to wake them up
that they might get to talk about
something that gets them a little bit
excited and that in a weird way makes
you more memorable right like it it
actually makes you like oh she asked me
good questions i want to spend more time
with her
yeah yeah yeah
for me i think that um
the only way that we can feel empathy
the only way that we can feel compassion
the only way that we can feel less
loneliness i am very worried about
loneliness i think it's something that
i'm
i think we're becoming increasingly more
lonely the only way that we can fight
that
in a non-chemical way like not without
drugs is by knowing how to stay awake
having conversations that fuel us having
relationships that feel really um
supportive and incredible and giving
waking up and knowing that we can stay
off of autopilot and we're going to be
accepted for it
there's actually some really interesting
studies about ambivalence
so i used to have a lot of writing where
i write about toxic people difficult
people and that's a fascinating set of
science right how do we create
boundaries around difficult people how
do we create um walls and and say no to
difficult or toxic people
but actually what's more insidious are
ambivalent relationships so ambivalence
is are those relationships where
you could take it or leave it
you kind of like them but you're not
sure if they like you or you're not sure
if you like them
you never feel particularly charged when
you leave them you see them on your
calendar or you get a text from them and
you're not like lighting up
ambivalence is actually the sort of in
between okay what they found is that
they looked at police officers and they
asked them about their relationships
and their prediction was that
police officers who had difficult
personalities in their workplace would
have the least work happiness
but actually what they found is that
that was not the case that police
officers who worked with difficult
people knew they were difficult they
avoided them they didn't invite them to
lunch
they tried to not talk to them actually
was quite easy for them to be like
that's not my person
the police officers who had the lowest
rate of work happiness were the ones who
had the most ambivalent relationship
these were people they worked with where
they weren't sure do they really support
me
these are those people where you sit
with them and they make a comment and
you wonder was that passive aggressive
oh is that supportive or you share good
news and you're not really sure if
they're happy for you
those relationships are so draining and
when we are asleep when we are on
autopilot we don't get rid of them we
don't level them up we don't get them
out of our lives and so that ambivalence
i don't want you to have any
relationships or conversations where
you're feeling like you're half asleep
what's interesting is that i think that
we're talking a little bit both of us
are talking about sort of
giving names to our unconscious needs
desires and opinions right like making
them conscious like being awake to them
and one of the things that i found very
empowering that got me out of a lot of
my anxiety and my imposter syndrome was
understanding that there is a hidden
language that we're all speaking right
that we are constantly sending cues back
and forth and we are incredibly
contagious
so
what research has found is that when we
are around someone who is afraid we will
actually catch their fear without
realizing it there's a really gross
study i talk about this is my ted talk
it's very gross but i promise it's worth
it so here's what they did
they
uh brought people into the lab and they
split them up into two groups
the first group they had them run on the
treadmill wearing sweat pads so uh
pads that would catch their sweat while
they ran
and run the treadmill get really really
sweaty i took those wet pads the second
grew they said we're gonna take you
skydiving for the first time and they
had them wear the same
new set of sweatpads and they took them
up an airplane they pushed them out of
an airplane
this is new people yeah new people yeah
so people first time skydivers had to go
up wear these flat pads and they were
sweating fear sweat right like imagine
what you feel right before jumping on
the airplane i did yeah oh my gosh okay
yeah so that's sweat okay that's yeah
they took these sweatpads and they asked
unsuspecting new participants to smell
them
this is where kids grow
now imagine i know it's like it's real
nasty
these participants had no idea what they
were smelling they literally just
okay
and then they it's like here i think
this milk is off will you just tell can
you tell me if this milk is off or like
when someone said this smells horrible
smell this
yeah
so there's they smell both of these and
they put them in a brain scanner they
found when participants smelled the
sky-diving sweat pads their own fear
center their own amygdala began to light
light up
began to activate in other words when we
smell fear sweat even though we do have
no idea that it's fear sweat we begin to
feel afraid
this study has so many implications
because it shows that there is this
language that's happening with us even
on a chemical level it didn't even see
the person that we are constantly
picking up on each other's signals
and i think when we are awake
when we are
ready for those signals we know they are
affecting us we can take control of them
sure
the study that totally changed my life
so that i knew that cues were contagious
but i wasn't quite sure how was that
when we see negative cues we catch them
and our body actually changes so this
happens not only from a chemical
perspective from a nonverbal perspective
very simple they had participants come
into a room and they found that when
someone spotted a cue of social
rejection so acute social rejection
could be an eye roll
it could be a scoff
it could be a negative tone of voice
yeah great idea right yeah
when we spot that
our own field of vision increases
literally our pupils dilate to see more
and this is our body's way of going uh
oh
is there another key that's being sent
to us what's my escape route
and so i think that my other aspect of
being awake is knowing that these cues
are being sent to you being aware enough
to label them take control of them and
then respond with confidence
that that cycle is the most empowering
thing we can do i've never thought about
that that's a fascinating study to be
able to like do it off of smell um
gross but totally interesting
what about
what about energy and frequency like
what about
what about that when you can't smell
them but someone walks into the room and
you can just feel them there's this is
where it's really hard to parse out
energy
versus cues versus scent and we'll take
video for example right let's just look
at video right video i cannot smell you
danika you look like you smell really
good but i don't know right i just have
to guess right smell amazing okay that's
what i thought so
we take smell out of the equation we
take some out of the equation
i am looking at a couple of different
modes that you are transmitting things
to me so because we've removed smell
because we've removed touch right we
can't touch we can't shake hands we
can't give a hug
we are focusing on words so verbal vocal
and non-verbal
and so i think that when we talk about
energy we're actually talking about is
how we are transmitting signals with
those three modes so the first one is
words obviously the first few words we
say the second one is gestures posture
facial expressions and the last one is
our vocal so how we say our words sure
what research has found is about 60 to
90 percent of our communication is
actually just in the non-verbal category
so when we say energy i think when
someone walks into a room we are taking
in their gate like how they're walking
through the room we're taking in how
they wear their clothing we're taking in
how they say hello
here's a really specific example
when we are anxious when we are nervous
we are afraid let's take those those
skydivers right i guarantee you if you
were to ask those guy divers right
before they jumped out of a plane to say
hello to answer their phone hello
when we are anxious or afraid our vocal
cords tense and i'm going to do it for
you right now so you can hear so right
now my vocal cords are relaxed because
i'm having a good time we're chatting
but if i were to go into anxiety and i
tighten my vocal cords you can actually
hear that i go a little higher on my
vocal pitch and also i get a little bit
more vocal fry so my vocal cords are
tight it's very very hard to get out of
fry so i talk higher and also you can
hear it and the more i tighten my vocal
cords the harder it is for me to get any
kind of resonance
so what happens is when people are
really anxious they'll say hey
hello
and we can hear it yeah it's like the
ready to cry sort of sound too
oh yes actually it's a very good point
yes it's exactly what we sound like best
way me when i'm about to cry
so we're listening
right without even realizing it too when
someone walks in the room or hops on
video and says hey guys
well let's take it down the notch this
is the most anxious hey guys
okay that's the most anxious yeah and
the next level which i hear very often
is someone answers at the top of their
breath and this is because they've been
holding their breath the whole time
they're a little bit nervous they go hey
yeah totally hello
yeah and we're at this we're talking
about we are accidentally signaling um
anxiety versus now i'm gonna do the
opposites so what happens when i relax
my vocal cords and by the way you can
try this with me so hopefully you can
try this at home if you don't if you
don't mind this is a really helpful
exercise so what i want you to do danica
you're willing is yeah i want to take a
deep breath and i want you to say hello
at the top of your breath so hello
hello
there you go
way higher versus so now i want you to
take a deep breath and i want you to say
hello on the out breath it's going to
sound like this
hello
hello
right yeah totally
totally different so if you try that i
want you to ask yourself
what voice are you using
when you're
on video calls presenting talking to
your partner talking to your kids in an
interview are you up here
hey everyone it's so good to see you
or you down here
that is the that's energy i think we're
talking about energy
we can literally hear it